hello friends my name is elisa kelly and
i am the resident astrologer here at the
drew barrymore show and i am backstage
bts for a very special day
two two two two two two
[Music]
this is a meaningful monumental exciting
day and not just because it happens to
be drew barrymore's birthday which is
just incredible on its own but
this number sequence actually has a lot
of mystical and astrological
significance so perhaps you have looked
at your phone and have seen 11 11
and felt something monumental or maybe
you were trying to hail a cab and you
noticed that that cab happened to have
333 the truth is is that there is
something really magical and mystical
about a number sequence and this is
related to this theory called angel
numbers obviously it means something
different for everyone but no one can
deny that when you see repeating numbers
like two two two two two that it
actually has sort of a special power and
magic baked into it so i like to say
this thing called tank which means there
are no coincidences it could be that you
see these repeating numbers whether it's
11 11 or a series of threes or all of
these twos but you might also be tuned
in to numbers that are very specific to
you and to your life this is very
magical mystical esoteric stuff but you
get it and what's really interesting
about this date two two two two two is
that pluto for the first time ever is
going to be making a full rotation from
the day that the united states was
founded pluto will be making its first
complete orbit the united states is
experiencing what's called its first
pluto return and of course we can't
ignore that drew is going to be having
her solar return her birthday on the
same day that the united states is
experiencing its pluto return that's
pretty remarkable so when pluto return
happens we can anticipate that the
united states is going to be going
through a radical metamorphosis and the
thing is is that even though it is going
to be exact on this day on february 22nd
we've been experiencing this for quite a
number of years already this is not
something that just happens on a single
day and then it's done this is a process
we work up to this so everything that we
have been experiencing over the past few
years is very indicative of this united
states pluto return that is absolutely
going to
change the way that we experience what
it means to be in this country scary
when i say that
there are a lot of positives associated
with pluto return specifically the fact
that a lot of the things that have been
swept under the rug in the shadows
things that have been functioning but
not really being called out and
identified and seen are going to be
exposed during this time and this is
actually really meaningful because this
has the potential to do mass collective
consciousness healing which is going to
allow us to become a less polarized more
unified and more synchronized space so
that we don't feel like everything is as
extreme so i think that this actually is
going to be
really powerful really important and
something that is going to change our
lives for the better so whether you are
drew barrymore celebrating your birthday
or you are an astrologer excited about
the united states's first pluto return
or you are just someone who likes to
make a wish when you see repeating
numbers this is a very very special day
to tap in and to practice that beautiful
magic that exists within you thank you
so much if you want to find me catch me
on social media at elisa kelly and my
show celebrity astrology investigation
on people tv so happy birthday drew and
happy pluto birthday united states
be good
[Music]